good afternoon dear colleagues ladies
gentlemen so I have an honor and
privilege well to open today for the
first meeting was in the series of the
global governance and challenges to the
eastern and central Eastern Europe and
today we have it at our panel to
distinguished diplomats good colleagues
friends
excellency ambassador dr. Melissa the
honor which bridge can be represented
fontelle ago to the United Nations she's
the exact person to speak about the
security stability in the region
because primary to have appointment as
ambassador for many years for four years
she was Minister of Defense of
Montenegro so she was exactly expert on
on whatever in that sphere in the
Balkans so but ambassador the Honorable
George is our colleague she has a big
experience in academic she has full
doctorate in information technologies
she presided a lot of the enterprise's
private was at the vice dean at the
university to represent her country in
European structures on that issue well
she was ambassador almost at the same
time to france and monaco and unesco
when I was there I left before she got
employment ambassador to State Univ
Serbia Montenegro Belgium Luxembourg
member of the Parliament for nine years
so ambassador is exact exact panelists
to answer a lot of the questions and
sharing with us her country was probably
the only country in the in the region
who who managed not to be involved in
any
good story a good example for the room
for the region we will speak about that
the the next guest is a good friend
colleague of mine dr. Angela Angela is
Bulgarian diplomat and academician well
we work together in some institutions
teaching at United Nations Institute for
training and research and in Columbia
University and now he is here he is
doctor he had his career studied in
Cambridge in Europe and Italy and he is
an excellent expert in conflict
prevention conference management and he
is representing his mission at the 4th
political committee of United Nations an
expert group on the United Nations
Security Council agenda which is very
important body and if if you are
interested in any capability of this
body to manage the world crisis and to
prevent them his exact person on that
but with that I would ask ambassador can
we do research to to start our
discussion we will try to touch as many
problems as the region has since long
ago historical ethnic economic energy
whatever but what is more important for
us today her country successful story
which is very important for all the all
the region and they are the post
Yugoslavia countries not Germany example
is important for them but Macedonia
Macedonia and Montenegro is very
important because they emerge from the
same problems with that Melissa you have
from you can see or you can stand or
tell whatever you want whatever you
prefer
okay Thank You Yuri and thank you of
Macmillan Center for organizing this
afternoon
debate of this kind the weather is not
really favourable and maybe that is the
reason why there is no more of you but
anyway there are the means thanks to
technology so that our discussions could
outreach a little bit more outside this
room anyway Zuri said I'm someone who is
from the Academy the first place and
coming from the small country which is
in transition for destinies now's a lot
of people from Academy felt obliged to
enter the politics and try to help the
development and transition of our
countries by our knowledge experiences
and competencies and I'm one of them so
in parallel with my academic career I
was doing many things in our politics in
Montenegro and Vidor being a diplomat
for a couple of years and also pursuing
my professorship either in Montenegro or
other places all the time and since I
mean technologies of course and since
I've been very much involved as a
Minister of Defence in a very
challenging phase of montenegro session
to NATO now there is very much focus on
the issues which our great sexuality
issues related with cyber security and
similar anyway here today we need to
talk about the challenges when it comes
to security in our part of the world and
how do we perceive that from the region
of Western Balkans talking about Western
Balkans you do know that that word is
having different meanings depending on
how we do understand the thermals such
nowadays of course we prefer talking
about southeastern Europe because of
these
controversies but anyhow what is the
good news is the returnees done a great
deal of progress in the last destinies
at the first place
so after everything which was so
complicated in the period after the
transition from the previous system and
after the Cold War and all these
alliances that were of the past fall
down we in the region try to do our best
and to actually be as much successive
successful as possible in embracing
democratic values and democratic norms
and principles in the countries that we
are making a part of ex-yugoslavia that
was especially challenging because of
the dissolution which hasn't been done
in a way which would be favorable to
that goal so as you all do know there
are a number of conflicts atrocities so
bad things happened and of course I'm
very proud of the fact that at that time
I've been at the top of Montenegrin
politics where we had that awareness
that our priority was to kept the peace
in our country and that was something we
managed to do so Montenegro hasn't been
a part of any war in the
region of ex-yugoslavia we kept
ourselves together because it was very
important from the point that Montenegro
is a country where you are having all
different people different religions
different nations different ethnicities
and it was really very important not to
have any kind of these conflicts inside
the small country as Montenegro was so
after we succeeded in that there was a
number of challenges afterwards you know
in 1999 there was a Kosovo war there
were those actions of NATO in order to
stop everything which was happening
there also that was a challenge of
Montenegro as at that time we received a
number of refugees which equal to the
third of our population and we managed
that well as well so afterwards we were
preparing for regain our independence
you do know that mooning Montenegro was
recognized as one of a couple of dozens
countries in Europe at the Berlin
Congress in 1878 and then due to
different historical developments at one
point after the first world war we lost
our independence II later on we were
part of Yugoslavia we can't complain
that that part of history was bad for
our country but still after the
dissolution of Yugoslavia we were very
much patient in taking that next step in
regaining our independence II and we
were patient because of what I told you
before because of the fact that our
neighbor at that time the North neighbor
which was Serbia under the Milosevic
regime wasn't that much welcoming that
kind of idea for Montenegro to become
independent and we wanted to restate our
independency in a democratic way so not
by the war not by the conflict and
finally our patience paid off and in
2006 we organized the democratic
referendum where we reached the
independent Montenegro we were very
proud of the way how we did that because
every party took part in this referendum
process we agreed on the conditions we
agreed on the way how the campaign will
be built how the majority will be
defined and you do have that very unique
case in a democratic world of the
required majority for that referendum to
be successful it was fifty five plus
votes which was acquired for challenging
from the point of the basic democratic
rules because normal it should be 50
plus but actually they wanted to have
the real result which would be perceived
as a success of everyone who was taking
part in that process we agreed and we
managed to get the results which was
needed and we managed to have all the
parties recognizing the result of the
referendum and the new era started for
Montenegro the new era which was marked
with the two basic foreign policy
priorities related with our integration
in European Union and in NATO so we
actually have chosen these two parts
because we were convinced and we still
are that these are the best way to
sustain the peace and stability not only
when it comes to Montenegro but the
whole region of southeastern Europe so
Montenegro became a part of NATO after
the whole process of years of reforms in
political system in the security system
and after we fulfilled all technical
requirements I would say then there was
a lot of politics there and finally we
got a green line from at that time 28
member countries in it--all becoming
29th now we all hope and we are
welcoming already the 33 trees the
Republic of Nauru Macedonia and of
course we are on the side of those that
do think it is the right way for the
the country's the southeastern Europe
which are still lagging behind to go the
same way because that is the way how by
enabling security for your society and
by enabling security for your population
you will be able to go a step forward
towards a better progress in what is
economy what are the projects important
for the development of your society of
course everyone who was on the side that
we somehow were taking security as
something which is granted at least our
generations but unfortunately in the
last couple of years it became obvious
that the situation is a little bit
different that we've got to invest
ourselves if we want to live in a
society which could be considered a
secure one the society which will then
have all necessary preconditions to go
forward in enabling a better standard
for their citizens in that sense of
course being a member of NATO now and
being a front-runner in the process of
European integrations Montenegro is
there for every other country to share
the experiences to be a part of every
process which could resolve remaining
issues still in our region we are very
glad at the issue of the name between
now Republic of northern Macedonia and
Greece has been resolved that's one of
the greatest achievements lately in our
region we do hope that very soon
conditions will be met that some kind of
problems will be noticed when it comes
to the conflict between I mean conflict
in that sense bad sense of the world but
unresolved issue between Kosovo and
Serbia we do believe that Bosnia and
Herzegovina will recognize themselves
that they got to sit together and make
the state functional state and there of
course Montenegro is always at the
forefront to offer our services in order
to have the dialogue and to have the
open and transparent there
which will result in the solutions when
it comes to our region and it's better
off for the tomorrow so from that point
on I am very open for everything which
might be interested to you and I would
prefer to have interactive discussions
so in that manner I would know what are
you really interested in thank you Thank
You Melissa thank you for this short
comprehensive story of success of your
country and I have no doctor angle angle
of initially I asked him well to to
focus on Macedonia and Kosovo but
representing Bulgaria which is the also
the part of the Balkans they could
expand his narrative including his own
country and plus other are the issues
about the security and stability in the
region and then after his statements so
I will open the floor to all of us for
questions answers
thanks for inviting me and thanks for
the Million Center for hosting us now
deliver the presentation which I called
Balkan ghosts and the United Nations
I'll start 10 years ago when I came
first to New York actually the first
meeting I attended was Kosovo it was a
request from Serbia to receive to
request an opinion at the International
Court of Justice Weiser opinion about
the legality of the declaration of
independence of Kosovo so that was my
first day October 8 2008 and once the
votes talk place I quickly tried to
figure out how the other Balkan
countries voted so I was doing that
pretty quickly because the the screen is
changing and I get a problem to find one
of our neighbors our Western neighbor
with a capital scope here and you know
and her excellency already mention about
the name disputes between scorpion
audience so I was aware that in ninety
three that country was accepted as a
member of the UN under the provisional
name of the Former Yugoslav Republic of
Macedonia so when I try to look at the
screen I looked at F Former Yugoslav
Republic of Macedonia no wasn't there
then I thought maybe Republic of
Macedonia ,
the Former Yugoslav Republic No so this
is just scream what do you think you
could find that country
the Former Yugoslav Republic of
Macedonia so then I thought ok I have
some basic background of the Balkans I
used to study in the Balkans outside of
my country also I used to teach Balkan
politics still when I came to the UN I
had difficulties finding the name of one
of my neighbors so I figure out the UN
has its own dynamic and in the most
modern 10 years I've been trying to
figure out how it works and the way the
Balkan conflicts are tackled by the
United Nations and expectancy already
mentioned the dissolution of Yugoslavia
was not fairytale
it was raffia who was supposed many
people believe at that time before the
of this happened that it will be the
first former communist country that is
going to join the European communities
because Yugoslavia was much ahead of all
the other socialist countries including
my own Bulgaria the use of people could
travel abroad which was pretty difficult
for us and almost impossible for some
other countries in the region
unfortunately didn't work out well
because there were the wars and as a lot
of the previous speakers mentioned
pretty much everybody left Yugoslavia
with a war with the noble exception of
Montenegro and partially of what is
nowadays called North Macedonia so first
it was the so-called ten-day wars in
Slovenia then the pretty much more
significant war in Croatia
then how enable Western able to see
Bulgaria's next to it declared
independence under the name Republic of
Macedonia and my country was the first
one in the world that recognized
Republic of Macedonia under his
constitutional name
however they were allocated then what
happened was the boy a war in Bosnia and
it's pretty much
the worst war in Europe after the Second
World War and then in 99
it was the war in Kosovo 2001 it was the
insurgency in Macedonia and then the
success story of Montenegro that split
away of the at that time um Serbia and
Montenegro after successful referendum
that was a spiritual dimension pretty
tricky but it worked out and then Kosovo
declared independence and what we have
now really right now is the success
story Greece and Republic of North
Macedonia and I'm going to speak more
about it later on so the context of all
those conflicts the UN invested a lot
they sent plenty of missions all those
are closed now except the star star is
Olmec UN mission in administration in
Kosovo interim administration in Kosovo
in addition to all of those resources
the UN sent some of its brightest
diplomats available Martti Ahtisaari who
later on got the Nobel Peace Prize Kofi
Annan the late secretary-general of the
UN who also got the Nobel Peace Prize
also was at some point sent as an envoy
to the Balkans then you have for example
car built the another European diplomat
and Sergey d-mail who was the Special
Representative for Iraq and he was
killed in his mission during his mission
over there so after all of those
resources both financial military and
human still the things didn't go well
and when many of you may figure out who
are those people
this is one of the biggest
areas of the UN this is Serb ronita it's
when there was a safe haven that was
supposed to protect the refugees there
the people looking internally displaced
people persons people who were looking
for safe haven the UN was supposed to
protect them probably due to
insufficient resources procedures and
all of this didn't work out what you see
on this picture is Rock College who was
the military commander of the Bosnian
Serbs and the guy the gentleman in the
middle is the commander of the UN force
I mean they're pretty much taken as
hostages the very peacekeepers because
they couldn't really match the firepower
of the Bosnian Serbs but nevertheless
this is what happened as a result of the
UN not being able to fully fulfill its
promises so these goals from our past
keeps counting cars
it comes to the to the UN in different
forms every six months there is a
resolution sometimes they're
extraordinary resolutions like this one
which was about celebre nitsa declaring
it a genocide and due to different power
struggles between the great powers and
geopolitics Russia for example voted
against that particular resolution then
every year the UN Security Council has
to renew the mandate of the EU mission
European Union mission over the in
Bosnia some years a few years ago for
example Russia abstains because he
didn't want references to the Eurotunnel
integration of Bosnia which later on
disappeared another conflict from the
region the Kosovo conflict as a result
of the conflict there taking place
between the Kosovo Albanians and Serbia
there was the NATO military operation
you
Rico in 99 and as a result of this
another ghost comes the yuan and up to
him how it came four times a year now
there was a big fight between on one
hand the Russian Federation on the other
UK US and other Western countries to
reduce the amount of meetings in the UN
Security Council on Kosovo on one hand
Russia China Serbia they want the issue
to be discussed they make a point that
the situation calls to threat to
international peace and security at the
same time other players wide the US
while the UK they say okay it's not an
ideal situation but things change Kosovo
is much more stable than it used to be
he doesn't want to continue four times
to meet four times a year and the major
players on the side of Kosovo and Serbia
this is the Serbian first Deputy Prime
Minister and foreign ministry with the
Dutch and on the consumer side currently
it's the ambassador of Kosovo to to DC
before that they used to send their
Deputy Prime Minister and foreign
minister hashim tachi who is currently
the president of Kosovo another case we
have from the region the Republic that
was accepted in the UN as the Former
Yugoslav Republic of Macedonia during
the wars in Swabia the rest of
Yugoslavia the UN deployed un uniforme
it's it's a mission that is supposed to
prevent it to be prevented redeployed so
to stop the spillover of conflict from
Yugoslavia and to an extent it was a
pretty good example of what the UN
should do because everybody speak is
that it's not enough to send military
peacekeeping missions after a conflict
it's much better to act preemptively so
to stop the conflict before spillover
comes however at that time Republic of
Macedonia decided to recognize Taiwan
and allegedly they believe they'll get
foreign investments like 1 billion
dollars it didn't work out when the UN
mission was supposed to be renewed there
was a veto you know China is a permanent
member of the UN Security Council and
has the right to use veto in that case
for the renewal of the UN operation but
been in 2001 there was insurgency in
Macedonia between the majority of the
country of the population and the
O'Banion minority which the last time I
think it was measure it in 2001 2002
probably 2002 I think and there were 25
point 17 so a quarter of the population
in Republic not Macedonia nowadays had
issues with the with the government
there was an insurgency as a result of
that Macedonia realized that their own
needs they may need the support of China
in the castle and this is what happened
they recognized China again People's
Republic of China and then another
conflict what Macedonia had and both the
previous speakers mention about that
Macedonia it's also geographic region
and as you see it's it split between the
nowadays Republic of North Macedonia
Greece and that corner over there is my
own country
area when Macedonia declared
independence in 91 it was the first
country then that she did without the
wall but as I said the volcano bit
afterwards so then they started using
different symbols which Greece perceived
as an attempt to steal their history for
example this is the start of Regina the
son of Aegina and obviously Greece was
not satisfied with what happened there
were protests there was an embargo they
in a way were able not to let the
country that code itself officially
Republic of Macedonia to join the UN
under that name and here you see a copy
of the Security Council resolution from
93 that recommends the General Assembly
to accept the new country under the
provisional name their former use of
Republic of Macedonia hence they
literally used the name and that's why
they used to put the country under the
letter T and as a result mustard on you
had to change their flag to this one but
still the tensions continued due to the
name dispute Republic of Macedonia
couldn't join NATO couldn't join the
European Union the response was that
that is copier they built plenty of
statues showing a connection between the
nowadays citizens of the country and the
ancient past there were plenty of them
including about the the mother of
Alexander Co she was pregnant Josh was
breastfeeding and now Alexander is boy
it didn't work very well
CNN called this theme park
for example the airport was named
Alexander the Great the motorway was
named
example degrades and the negotiations
didn't go anywhere
that's my to Nimitz he was the invoice
working for decades on this but what
happened is that just to less than two
years ago the new prime minister of
Macedonia Zorn's F and prime minister of
Greece
tsipras they were able to find a way to
navigate out of this conflict of lust
it's already closed 27 years so it's a
result of that you see the foreign
minister of Greece at the sculpey
airport why is this picture historic
because between 2006 and 2008 when the
name of the airport was changed
no Greek official would fly to just copy
with an airplane in or not to go to the
Alexander the Great Airport so once
Republic Macedonia change the name of
the airport it was the first visit of
the Greek foreign minister since 2006 at
the at the airport and he played a very
important role in the in the name
resolution and very quickly you see the
name Alexander the Great from the
airport is removed the motorway is
already friendship motorway not
Alexander the Great and here is the
historic act in presper it's it's a lake
between both countries when you see the
two foreign ministers and the two prime
ministers of the countries signing the
Accord and the statue of Alexander the
Great's the name was change and now it's
a symbol of friendship between
Macedonian please and the most important
thing the change of the name of the
country that was what was just a few
weeks ago and this is how they change it
to Republic of North
Macedonia of course not everybody in
Greece was happy
neither everybody in Republic of North
Macedonia was happy and even the
president of North Macedonia spoke
against this agreement this happened in
September at the UN general debate and
he he made the case against the press /
agreement he said that it was not signed
by him and it's a flagrant violation of
the right of self-determination
nevertheless also the Russian Federation
was not happy with this they at some
point the Foreign Ministry for Russia
the Russian Federation said that is a
permanent member of the UN Security
Council Russia's closely monitoring the
developments of this situation and in a
way many media's interpreted that Russia
is going to veto the resolution of the
name dispute it cannot because a
Republic of North Macedonia even though
with a changed name was accepted as a
member in 93 so you don't need another
Security Council resolution to recommend
the General Assembly the acceptance of
the new member and now this is just a
few days old the countries under the
name on to the letter n North Macedonia
and the flag of North Macedonia is
already put between the flags of Nigeria
and Norway and wrapping up with this all
of those issues we discuss they discuss
in the council and of course you have
the the main players who have their own
interests their own understandings of
those conflicts and all of them were one
way or another involve in trying to find
the solution of the conflict and of
course you that reminded me a bit
it's a moment from the debates on
Ukraine he remembers those moments it's
the former Russian ambassador
to present from bass the chicken in the
former American permanent representative
Ambassador Samantha power and there is
another player
this was the Embassy of China in
Belgrade which was bought in 99 and just
illustration that China also has a stake
in some of those conflicts in the
resolution of those conflicts like this
if you graphic shows you the issues that
are discussed in close consultations in
the UN Security Council and the more the
issue is discussed the larger there are
the name is and we're pretty happy to
see that you have only one Balkan
conflict Kosovo over there discussing
close consultations and that's ICQ why
to be on for four maybe Swabia but it's
it's not directly related to that so my
hope is that soon the issues from my
region from the Balkans will completely
disappear from the agenda of the council
thank you crash analysis session I have
many questions
Javed panelists and all together we will
try to figure out where we are on the
Balkans so sorry food from your last
slides you reminded us the successful
story between Greece and Macedonia two
leaders who the tsipras and Zoran as I
have they met in Munich recently in the
Security Council security conference
they were awarded there they had the
same panel at the same panel we we saw
two other leaders
the president from Serbia voltage and
the president of Kosovo touch so my
question is is it promising sign
they were sitting speaking together is
demonstrating the good relations between
themselves or there is some science some
some beliefs that the relations between
the two will improve how we should
accept this beside thank you okay will
be very brief on that that meeting I
don't think it went very well for the
two presidents but we've experienced
this even before in the Security Council
at some point the representatives of the
both countries were fighting at some
point they were handshaking after the
meetings and then again fighting so it's
not an easy conflict it's about the
territory your integrity sovereignity so
both countries are pretty sensitive and
the time is not really it doesn't seem
to be too ripe for for a big change but
there is a pressure pressure comes first
from the successful recent successful
experience with Greece and North
Macedonia then there is a pressure from
the United States very very recently and
very serious pressure that came and the
European Union which is facilitating the
process is also applying pressure so I
don't really expect a breakthrough but
as a result of this pressure I think
they should change the gear and first
come back to negotiations which are
interrupted as Melissa Montenegro is
exactly able to go to Serbia to Co so
what do you feel from Montenegro if any
positive results could come soon well
actually as someone who has been engaged
in many processes we all supports very
much the fact that there is a doubt it's
so important so
we could have a different perception of
what the results of them sitting
together and having those negotiations
on the field of course not that much and
there are some I would say backslashes
lately with those taxis that were
introduced by Kosovo and then Serbia
does not wanting to perceive our
negotiations while attracts Isan and
they lost or the whole region lost a
couple of months it seems now that the
situation is changing and the tax might
be read withdraw but something is
happening definitely and I would say
that the main point there is that there
is a certain rise of awareness on both
sides that the debt situation should go
forward with some kind of solution of
course always it needs a lot of time
it's very complex it's very sensitive
and as you said it's related with the
theaters integrity and sovereignty and
of course respecting the fact that
everything has been done in a democratic
way it comes to cost so in the
referendum and it's in fact that we all
recognize Kosovo after that but still
we've got to understand the Belgrade as
a search and from that point on we do
believe and somehow I believe that we
might have some positive developments
very soon I mean it won't be that easy
but as I said both presidents which I
engage in this dialogue I would say are
trying the way to go forward great so
the next question about NATO accession
to NATO membership in NATO what did it
mean to your country and to the region
and anger a question to you so recently
less than a month ago
a month ago Macedonia got the invitation
to join NATO
during the next
I mean what it will mean for the for the
region for the security of the region
that is very important as I said
security comes before everything else so
coming from the region with these
experiences of very turbulent history
not only in the 90s but I mean in a very
fuzzy fast history this was the place
where our different people different
cultures different religions were mixing
together were East met West and we're
today you are having in this I would say
global game of changing the
international order we used to know some
of them how we call them great power who
are trying to put their footsteps in
that region for obvious reasons you know
this is the part of the world which is
as I said crossroad between East and
West between south and north so I
remember when I was argument to drive
for Montenegro is important to be a part
of NATO and vie for NATO is important to
have Montenegro as a part of this
alliance at that time Montenegro was you
know we are having our course which is
really a three ethoxy and at that time
it was only our part of the coast which
is some 300 kilometers which was at the
north coast of the old Mediterranean
Basin which wasn't in NATO so for later
as well it was crucial to seal this
Mediterranean north bounds from the
point of security be present we be there
to not to be offensive towards anyone to
be there to provide security first of
all for the countries as abstract to
build our capacities together by pooling
and sharing what we are having as
resources to have a better response to
what our global challenges today not to
mention everything
related with terrorism with the climate
Ranger ease with economical financial
crazy so there is a member of them and
from that point for Montenegro it was
important and we somehow considered a
membership in nature as a seal to our
independence II you know we don't expect
really to be quite frank with you we
don't expect any kind of armed conflicts
anymore in the region I think we did our
share history in that sense but still
there is so many things going on which
could undermine what you are doing what
are your plans watch what is not only
your politics you see what is happening
with the elections everywhere then you
see what can happen with the economy
everywhere as well so for a small
country to have a response and such a
huge challenges not very well known to
anyone nowadays I would say is always
better to be a part of the club because
it's impossible today to do that on our
own and I mean allow me I think it's
impossible for the huge countries as
well like the country we are at the
moment so partnerships and the
transatlantic partnership in the first
place which proved to be the most
effective partnership that we had after
the second world war in Europe it
assured that Europe was able to develop
as a whole free and at peace after
everything which was happening in the
second world war it's in Morocco and I
do believe the transatlantic partnership
in a to himself has a great deal of role
in what happened so from that point on I
do believe that for the balcony - what
was the reaction from Belgrade do they
like that for our NATO membership
I believe they don't like that but I got
to say that at the official level since
they also have gone a great deal of
development in the last decade I would
say the government of Alexander
Woodridge was the government who
actually officially understood our
reasons thank you
Veolia yes no Macedonia thank you
actually fully subscribed to what we'll
just said a few things to add first
today
my own country in the Powerman to
Bulgaria they adopted the the protocol
for accession of Republic of North
Macedonia so it's a process that's
really going on as we speak
first it happened in Greece because that
was part of the understanding but of the
press per agreement so what does it mean
again everything that were just said I
fully subscribed to it few other things
to add speaking as a citizen of Bulgaria
pretty much we believe that in order to
anchor ourself what we want the couple
of steps that has to be made pretty much
the ultimate is the European Union
membership but the experience in our
part of the world show that every East
European country that I wanted to join
you first joined NATO and that was why
Cassio a certificate that the minimum
amount of democratic changes is
accomplished so the EU membership is the
next step it's not automatic at all and
nowadays things are getting much more
difficult with the enlargement fatigue
with the breaks it and all of those
issues so it's definitely getting even
more difficult than it used to be and it
used to be difficult but now it's much
more difficult and this step for North
Macedonia first is a step further step
for them to continue their process of
post communist transition and
integration into the West and second I
also don't expect and hope no conflict
to come to our region and we had the
fair share as it was just said but
nevertheless it's pretty important that
there is another country which security
is supposed to be at a much higher level
because I showed you only in 2001 there
was an insurgency that was that could be
described as a war so it was not that
far away and being a member of NATO I
really believe it's going to stabilize
give a level of further stability of the
country and the region now a big group
of countries from the region full
membership Montenegro has the status of
candidates in since four thousand ten
nine something like that
2010 seems to me would it be easy know
when Europe in itself in problems well
to to get this membership so easily what
do you think what are the obstacles here
what are the challenges on that way
because you're the closest now yeah we
are so-called frontrunner leader in the
process because we started actually the
process before the others were still on
that way of integration if it's Serbia
also they are candidate yeah they also
candidate country of course and they
also they have you know how this process
from getting the candidature and
becoming full membership is going
through this long process and very
challenging and difficult process of
negotiations which is actually the
process where you are implementing those
needed reforms and these negotiation
process is done through chapters
it's 34 chapters which are actually
encompassing all these important areas
for the reforms of the whole political
social and economical system of the
country so when we started the
negotiation process this process has
been a little bit changed due to the
experienced European Union was having
with some of the countries that became
membership before in the previous round
which is actually Bulgaria and Romania
where they gathered that they could do
more during the negotiation process
before the membership in comparison what
they did so they put in front of us
varies a little bit modified strategy
where they actually prioritized two
chapters which are dealing with
democracy and rule of law so we started
them first there were very tough
conditions to open those two chapters
and start negotiations on them and they
said that they will be the last closed
so these are the issues they recognized
as a very important for the country to
be a full member of the European Union
so in the meantime in parallel we did
working on these chapters we opened
almost all the others and the all
sectors of our society engaged in
negotiations with the Union and actually
in these reforming the whole society and
of course at one point it was going well
then there were some slowdowns I want to
say that there might not be some
slowdowns because of our effectiveness
but actually the major reason is the
situation within the European Union so
there been certain crises we all know
that's the big global economical
financial and social crisis that hit
also the European Union and then a
certain slowdown when it comes to
enlargement and getting new members and
as you said a certain fatigue because of
the way how this big Alliance ISM
operating so from that point at one
point
would say we thought that we might get
the membership quite quickly but then it
was clear that not because of husband
because of the situation in EU there was
no guarantee of on that till 2015 or
something like that when are some of the
developments in our neighborhood show to
Brussels and the European Union that if
they pull out like that from our part of
the world then there will be some other
players coming in and I don't think that
it might be interest of everyone and
that's what they thought
obviously so they started so-called
Berlin process trying to bring in some
momentum in what is going on from the
point of European integration of our
region but I don't think it was very
effective as the result of everything is
still weighted and on the other side
there was a new strategy from Brussels
on node enlargement when it comes to
Western Balkans or remaining countries
saying that we might hope that in 2025
something could happen which I don't
think it's a very good I would say
approach of the European Union as
they're obviously due to these internal
issues there is no willingness to see
the enlargement as the possibility to
actually reinforce the Union to have the
new momentum a new energy in the Union
and since we are now all expecting with
the great attention what will happen
with the European elections which I made
this year we will probably know better
how the things will develop in the
future we are doing our part of the
world and I do believe that if some
greater perspective would be given from
the part of European Union we would be
ready to be a membership in a very short
and then learning thank you I believe
some time for questions from the
audience well please present yourself
and briefly your question and to whom
you are going to address it
[Music]
so the question is very important
because so it's it's interesting because
Christianity is becoming a part of the
state independence well well and the
poor sort of church in some of the
countries they are looking to be
independent from the Serbian Church they
are trying to follow the Ukrainian
example now it's not easy
well I'm not sure I understand your
question
probably that is what the polls are
showing when they've been talking with
the population but in all our countries
we are having a secular Republican
systems the turkey is completely
separated by the government and that is
quite clear so from that point I mean as
far as I do know in a majority of these
countries there are no intentions of
that kind I mean that would be a kind of
going a retrograde need we know
comparison what we achieved on the other
side the issue of religion is is very
important for the overall I would say
atmosphere in the countries and there
are when I say that I do have an example
of this couple Orthodox churches which
are in our region and where these issues
of the autonomy is on the table we
recently did have a new development in
Ukraine and we are of course having some
similar tendencies in the Republic of
North Macedonia and in Montenegro when
it comes to their relation with the
serbian orthodox church all that in
atmosphere for example in montenegro we
are having serbian orthodox church being
very much politically sound
and clear and very much trying to be
involved in some of the strategic
political processes going on in the
country like it was our NATO accession
one of the major opponents or one of the
main proxies of those who were against
our NATO membership was the Serbian
Orthodox Church in Montenegro but
actually that is something we are
dealing with very transparently in a
political level of putting forward our
arguments having we did have a very
broad public discussion where we were
able to discuss with our citizens or
positive or possibly negative sides of
our NATO accession to bring them and to
familiarize with what all that means and
I do believe that now we managed to go
forward in respect to the arguments that
were present from the other side where
the church was one of the main I would
say spoke institutions so it is always
present and that is something I think we
should be dealing with in a transparent
way in a public way by engaging in
dialogue with whoever might be having
that kind of intention to influence the
public opinion thank you
the EU Constitution which is part of the
Lisbon Treaty clearly states that state
and church or religion must be separate
if if any candidate country tries to
basically go counter that they will be
not admitted so that you know you you
you need to be reading the Lisbon Treaty
which clearly states that my question to
either one of you is you know based on
the experience that the EU made with
countries like Poland and Hungary don't
you think that it was a bit too
premature to admit these countries to
the European Union because they signed
off on the on the treaty accession
treaty but then they have been basically
especially when it comes to Poland and
Hungary saying Christianity is the
determining factor and and basically
saying anyone that is not Christian
should not be admitted don't you think
that was a bit premature and that is one
of the reasons why the European Union is
now reluctant to move very quickly to
admit new members thank you thank you
just to build on what you asking and
what was it was said the conditionality
for joining the European Union has
always been a moving target and with the
time and based on experience the newer
and newer conditions more strict
monitoring implemented and I guess it
will get even harder and harder the the
examples you gave were until very
recently considered the most successful
examples of new members joining the
European Union I very well see your
points I am familiar well even even
politically
Poland was the one with sulla darkness
and moving in in that direction for
democratization the the Vichy grad
countries
Poland Czech Republic Slovakia Hungary
where those who initially reminded the
West that in the way you abandoned us
during the after the Second World War
your left us in another part of the
world we share your values we share your
norms we want to be members of the coop
so that was a huge pressure that was
applied and it worked so I see your
point again and that could be proven by
all of the processes internal processes
at the you the you that question
different aspects of the of the politics
or approaches of those countries but I
would not go that far to say that it was
premature at the time when they were
accepted they were considered to be
success countries change different
governments come to power and leave
power and you you see in so many other
countries so let's not hurry that much
into that direction your point is valid
but let's see what situation will be in
five years and I believe they will be
again one of the goods EU members let's
just be patient
well I'm not sure that's so important
reason I got to be quite sincere because
that quad that hesitation from the part
of Russell's dated before everything
change in these countries you're
mentioning and we should be aware that
some of those changes they are due to
change circumstances I mean they're been
that big challenge for the European
Union in 2015 with the refugees migrants
and everything and that started a lot of
things we've been involved in that as
well because you know those people were
passing through the Balkans and at that
point European Union was more than
willing to cooperate with us because it
was important and it showed that without
cooperation you can do anything so from
that point I believe also if we are
making a reduction you would come to the
point it's very important to help you in
it's better to have you in the note so
it's very important also for the Union
to consolidate themselves and to have
the mechanisms to give the right
responses situations arrive that
something we can't always foreseen but
we've got to have mechanisms to be able
to get to the responses and there it
might be some kind of issues as we see
nowadays also with what is happening
with brexit it's also and president but
still I mean you are as strong as you
are able to face the situations like
that yes thank you
it's not easy issue because it's about
the sovereignty and how many serenity we
are pulling to the to the Brussels the
reason that United Kingdom decided to
move out because
they recounted that too much serenity
were moved in that's why the discussion
in czech republic czech brazil in greek
brags it and so on it's about the how to
preserve serenity be part of the moon of
the bigger community so of course it's
it's not easy story how to adapt
yourself but when we are speaking about
the religion what at least in ukraine
what we are thinking about of course
it's part of our super anything but of
course we want to to be a church of of a
venetian identity in the performance of
reality but when from outside the other
church is interfering based on the
previous context and so on so on
brotherhood motherhood or whatever and
so when they are interfering through our
own churches in ukraine into the
politics it's a bit different the same
in that region when so the the
neighborhood in church in serbia namely
they are doing the same as the russian
church in moscow doing against in
against ukraine broadly so that's why
that's why it's to take the church issue
as not the interference of the
government of the church issue or the
some kind of the violation of the the
division of the church and and so a
church is a part of the of the nation
church is a part of the Serenity church
as a part of the identity and when
somebody is interfering in that identity
someone should protect it so it's not
easy other questions please
I have some some some few minutes what I
notice and I have a question if you
notice the same as I did so the
president of Croatia very visit to
Turkey plus last month and he together
with the president of Turkey they
declared that the Dayton agreements
should be revisited revised because they
don't work anymore
so it's it's interesting point
challenging point what if you if you
follow that territorial swaps
territorial changes demarcation those
issues have been mentioned more regular
than before recently that also concerns
the discussion started last year about
potential deal between Kosovo and Serbia
about territorial swaps it's a very
sensitive issue because in some areas
the idea of territorial swaps is better
accepted for example the Middle East
peace process everybody believes that
probably it will be based on the 1967
borders with territorial swaps between
Israelis and Palestinians in the Balkans
it's even more sensitive because the
wars were not that far behind and still
not that far behind us and any attempt
to change borders could get out of
control and even though for example in
Kosovo the president is in favor of
considering this option the Prime
Minister is strongly opposing both of
them used to be commanders in the army
for liberation of Kosovo both of them
were men who fault
and still some of them I mean they know
this could open doors it could mean a
recognition of Kosovo because it's only
a sovereign country that could negotiate
with another country about territorial
swaps at the same time once you open
this Pandora's box you're not sure if
you'll be able to close it and pretty
much it's the same about about the
situation in Bosnia for my personal
reading like everything I said it's in
my personal capacity I'm everybody
recognized that Dayton is not perfect
the thing is everybody has to look into
the context why Dayton came as the
courage
what kind of extremely sensitive balance
it was supposed to produce and of course
it's not perfect and of course there are
so many many other issues now with the
functioning of the states it's one of
the most sophisticated complicated
bureaucracies in the world but still any
attempt to redraw the map or redraw that
particular a coach could be tragic so
it's it hurts to say to give any any
comment on that about whether it's going
to work or not and that's why many
countries even from the biggest
countries in Europe they are very
reluctant to even to open this
discussion it's not perfect but somehow
it works if you break it who is going to
own it I mean it's a way to look for a
solution and we should all keep looking
for a solution but the time should be
arrived for for a particular solution
and if somebody tries to do it in the
wrong time it could be what I was
showing on the map okay so any any other
questions if not I have free discussion
around the reception so that's what I
mentioned a very important point so if
you repeat union is not active in in the
area some of you will come and today in
Europe broadly discussed the Chinese
Chinese coming as a risk for the region
oran is an opportunity because with this
initiative 16 plus 1 the central Eastern
European initiative inviting China
Chinese trying to invest in
infrastructure well building something
is it a risk challenges or these
opportunities or why European Union out
during the mini conference well they
raised at issue because it's complex and
it could be considered all the ways it
depends of course how we are handling
that but on the other side I already
said that at one point when the European
Union recognized that it might be a kind
of a threat they started to our etern
berlin process we were all very eager to
take part in it we went forward with a
number of infrastructure projects a
number of them which are which were a
kind of a joint infrastructure projects
many countries together which might be a
very good example for building up on
cooperation and cause relations with us
and from that time on years are passing
we don't see anything tangible in that
sense of course I know everything is
slow and everything but you know these
countries are very patient to go forward
they're very patient to go forward but
the time is running out new generations
are not that patient as we were and I
think it's good that they are not so
from that point they are trying to get
some faster solutions and
there are Chinese game so what is of
course good is to have this kind of
cooperation and initiatives but what
might be challenging is that all these
infrastructure projects are financed to
the loans which China is providing and
it's challenging from the point of
servicing those loans on the long term
on the other side and on the first side
from the point of keeping up the
standards when it comes to the quality
of this infrastructure which is built
around you do know that in Europe there
are some examples where that hasn't been
done in a well manner and the contracts
were broken so it's very much up to the
countries who are coming to this kind of
joint projects to be aware of all the
elements and put forward the mechanisms
to ensure both sides not to be in a
sense a real problem in the future VI in
Montenegro having a big infrastructure
which is a part of our highway which is
some 43 kilometers because because of
the configuration of Montenegro it's
mountainous specifically in the northern
part or in that continental middle part
it's very very expensive very
technically challenging and we did have
tender process international tender
we're really Chinese did have the most
favorable offer and that was very
difficult for the government and that
side to decide differently so different
mechanisms for controlling all aspects
of the projects are put in place so we
do hope that it will be done in a
with the quality level which is required
specifically for such a challenging
highway we are building there and from
the other point of course why the people
in European Union and I read also what
happened in the Munich conference last
week and security conference which I
attended many times as a Minister of
Defense previous and I do know that it's
an excellent platform for the exchange
now race they are concerned but there
we've got to ask where are the others
actually that's the right question so
where are the others would be actually
making all these kind of criticisms but
it's up to you as I said if you are not
around others having at least Chinese
are coming who is with money soft
approach soft intervention and your
country particularly you you had another
intervention during the election so
Russians are coming as well yeah but in
in a different manner that is in a
different manner we did have many issues
with Russia at the time of our new
accession which server and were pleasant
of course which were straightforward in
the sense that they did put forward
quite clearly there are disagreement
with our plans and with our strategy to
be a part of nature they were recalling
some kind of agreement at a time of
Gorbachev about agreeing coordinator not
to come to their borders so I was
actually
asking many times how and where anyone
could consider that Montenegro has
anything with the borders with Russia so
at the first place then on a second
who could be putting in question what is
the free will of one country or its
population so it our strategic goal to
become a part of nature and now to
become part of you has nothing to do
with anyone it has to do everything with
ourselves so from that point we've been
exposed to many different things which
are nowadays called the kind of hybrid
warfare where we haven't been very
prepared of course because we didn't
expect that but thanks to the fact that
we were really very much involved in
doing the reforms in security sector in
order to be prepared for NATO membership
we still were able to deal with that
until the variant thing that happened at
the time of our last parliamentary
elections in October 2016 and at the eve
of the our formal confirmation of the
NATO membership where some plans were
built to overthrow what were the results
of the elections or to attempt how now
it's a called Coupe de time Montenegro
where as far as we could see because the
trial for that is on for a year and a
half almost and it's publicly
broadcasted so everyone who is following
that could be see that there been some
involvement from that part of the world
which is Russia and Moscow it is not
quite clear whether it was backed up by
officials or it was some kind of
intelligence circles who were thinking
that they might prevent Montenegro on
achieving membership in NATO but again
we managed to deal with that as well and
again I do believe that it was really
directly thanks to the fact that we've
been doing so much on building our
capacities in security sector together
with the knight and our NATO friends and
allies and we were able to prevent any
kind of a problem at that evening which
was the evening of the our parliamentary
elections it's a failure of Russia
because they are losing losing potential
markets and the partners there and it's
interesting I read a few days ago that
even Serbia now is looking the
alternative energy sources for
themselves supporting the trance
antibiotic as you did I really small the
smart intervention who is as Chinese
trying to do or it is aggressive
intervention and then you're losing
whatever I have more questions on my
side I mean for the informal if you have
questions I can ask the last one and
then we move to the reception yes
map of the Balkans the only two
countries I mean Bosnia Herzegovina are
they a candidate country or are they
going to join the European Union are
they in discussions to join the European
Union do you support them joining the
European Union what do you do and the
same applies obviously to Albania
Albania is a part of NATO so what's your
stake it take on that well all the
countries are having when it comes to
European Union they are having this
target becoming the member so Albania is
supposed to start negotiations sometimes
this year together with the Republic of
Macedonia so they are there
well everything was delayed also do
certain requirements that as I said
following the new negotiations procedure
and strategy were put between Albania
and also it was for us I mean we got the
status of candidate and we had to work
another two years just to start
negotiations so it's very complex when
it comes to Bosnia Herzegovina they do
have also this kind of a priority and
they are trying to get into some closer
relations with nature as well and
somewhere in the table is still their
membership action plan that is the this
step which comes before their NATO
membership which can't be confirmed or
approved because of their internal
issues specifically there there is an
issue of the property of military
property and infrastructure
it's got to be registered so as they are
actually struggling with that they are
not going step forward so it's again the
issues which are related with the
internal political situations and the
internal relations where we come what
you mentioned whether for boss in
Herzegovina a new Dayton agreement or
the old one should be modified or not
that is something which is in the air
for years now so it seems that no one is
having really a kind of idea what to do
and the main thing would be for them
three there who are constitutional parts
of Bosnia Herzegovina would be having a
willing to think about their own future
and when it comes to Montenegro we
always there to help to each and every
of the countries in our neighbourhood we
also I didn't mention that but that is
also something which is showing our
approach toward the issues Montenegro
was the first one who Sai
the demarcation agreement out of all
these ex-yugoslavia
new states and it was with
bosnia-herzegovina then the second one
resigned which costs over there were
some problems there but still we managed
and we helped them a lot in order to
create a circumstances that it would be
favorable for them also to sign so from
that I think that in these very specific
terms we are showing how committed and
dedicated we are to help all our region
go forward so if if you need chronology
so whatever I have interesting that
Macedonia and Croatia obtained EU
candidate status in 2004 yes but for
Macedonia was frozen
because Montenegro got in 2010 Serbia in
2012 Albania in 2014
Croatia studied membership negotiations
in 2005 a year after the the obtained
candidates tears and completed only in
six years
in 2011 well and became the members only
in 2013 well so it's interesting well
the same with with NATO all the Balkan
states are the young members of
so-called partnership for pieces except
except Serbia Serbia has its all the
relations with NATO the individual plan
of partnership hostilities distilleries
okay thank you very much
[Music]
you